[Music]
welcome to mother one of New York's
hottest advertising agencies located in
Manhattan's Hell's Kitchen mother HQ is
nowhere near Madison Avenue this
building is special because it's one one
building it's one house of creativity
really and it isn't like your normal
office building where you ride an
elevator with a swipe your ID card
nothing is normal at mother a stuffed
bear access security who doesn't wanna
be agreed on something furry it has its
own art gallery we actually had a damien
hirst piece of art hanging here in the
peanut gallery complete with three
little earphones you could get an audio
tour in this little space and there are
shrines to former employees Gabriel he
was a Swede who had to move back to
Sweden he was known both for his great
demeanor and his mustache and so when he
left we took his mustache away we put it
there disgusting
I know mother's quirks showcased the
firm's creativity and it's layout
reflects a desire for collaboration
[Music]
there are no window offices at all in
this place it's everybody's it's mixed
in it doesn't matter if you're an intern
coming in or being here for ten years we
work a lot with the walls and on the
walls and this is not a exhibit this is
work in progress for our clients
everybody sees what's going on at all
times and can contribute if you want to
and it just gives a sense of a
collective spirit in this place the
heart of the office is in the kitchen
we're employees do their best
brainstorming the kitchen is such a
natural place for people to get to know
each other be comfortable with each
other and they work better together and
come up with better
that mother mom is always watching
that's my mom and is this all of the
mothers from all of your employees yeah
and they're not just on the walls that
is my mom amazing I love her hat
so is everybody's mom's picture on their
business card yes everybody's mom's
picture is off I need a mother business
card you know a mother is somebody who
who champions here stands behind you who
is in your corner and has your back and
we're that way very much for our
employees
[Music]